so yes we all agree cable news is
absolutely terrible and it's hard to
decide who is the worst on cable news
but the Washington free beacon put
together this little compilation of Al
Sharpton and take it away all these
divided at all it's not divided at all
make some friends make some friends for
the party of equality the party of
equality US policy has changed u.s.
policy has changed we are seeing at the
same time Liberty under assault Liberty
is under assault Democrats are feeling
the heat Democrats are feeling the heat
I didn't expect that that was gonna be
my lifetime's work he didn't expect it
to be his lifetime's work I think that
will be the demise of our republic the
demise of our Republic I'm not forgiving
ducks and deer weapons to shoot back at
me giving ducks and deer weapons to
shoot back at you what does that even
mean I think they're cooking the books
on this cooking the books in the way of
the people's priorities the people's
priorities nor do I recall anyone
believing that he doesn't recall anyone
believing that thank you for your
question thank you for your question we
have a weak and indecisive president
that invites ingression
the president invites agression it would
be an internship a dream come true is
time to move beyond this it's time to
move beyond this a trained eight could
get a Status of Forces Agreement a
trained
eight room really really room really
really really okay that is I mean that
goes on and on uh al7 is just absolutely
terrible but he's just one of the many
on cable news that are absolute oh he
might be the worst so let's just start
there mean we were all cracking up as we
were watching that how is that even how
does a producer sit there with him and
yet please I blame the producer on this
I think the producers and the writers
like they though that worked once yeah
and
oh let's do that thing where he says the
last four words as a question I don't
know that I blame al Sharpton on this
one I know just because I think for the
most part I think generally a lot of the
talking heads on cable news are just
reading the monitor of course they're
just reading the monitor but you know if
it's your name on the show then I know
you know like I'm home today and all
this but I'm just saying he D did not
work a while yeah
regardless that clip wins the Internet
like I guess like that's the funniest
thing I've seen in a while
who do you is there anyone off the top
your head on any of the networks that
you can think is worse cuz I watch in
every anyone on follows anyone not get
crazy here yeah so UT who do you like
then that's a more controversial topic
than who sucks we can agree that pretty
much they're all terrible there I got a
couple that I think are pretty decent
I'm gonna hold them in my pocket again I
like Rachel Maddow I like Melissa
harris-perry um I like Chris Hayes on
Saturday and Sunday morning more than I
like him on weeknights I don't know what
that's about but that's just the thing I
watching cause he seems like a little
kid they just put glasses on to make him
look smart but I know don't as recline
and Marcus Melissa's all look like the
sharpest minds on the eighth-grade
debate team I don't know what it is
about those guys they are so perpetually
doing yeah I'll give props to one guy on
CNN Jake Tapper I actually think is a
good reporter and he does it good in the
studio and then he goes out in the in
the field and does it um but we give too
much credit for all these people and I
say that with all do whatever cuz I'm
sitting here were online but I'm doing
the same the same thing but we put too
much stock in that they really at the
end of the day are just entertainers
more than but we more than reporters
we've sort of got that they're not
really reporters right right yeah I
think that their job is to make uh you
know the perception that there is a
commotion because that's what draws
viewers you know yeah where it just sort
of like it activates our amygdala which
is like our emotional Center the fear
center of the brain because that's what
people that's what you know it's not
good for us so much but it's good for
ratings yeah so why do some people just
terrible people just stick around like
someone like Al Sharpton who's been
terrible for like 30 years and has done
so much awful [ __ ]
and and is so biased
clearly not a good brother why do
terrible people just stay around you
know if you notice it was the Peter
Principle right though everyone rises to
the level of their own incompetence
I don't know me know why you know why is
Lindsey Graham still a senior seated
congressman you know why why I there's
it's amazing the people who have failed
to the top and certainly cable news
isn't any different I think that I'm
sure their cue ratings are good they
probably test market well or they focus
group whatever they're you know they
they solidly hit their demo of you know
thirty nine-year-old the UH denture
wearing retired you know some things I
don't know why you got me so the cameras
rolling last thing you wanna be is tepid
and benign especially on TV when you
know money time is money yeah so well I
do think that has a lot to do with it
that you're not going to get measured
people that are gonna show both sides
because yes then Huffington Post doesn't
write about what they say and everybody
wants click so then that that inherently
kind of destroys the truth